it is supposed to be the happiest day of
your life and the wedding industry is
built on a promise of perfection so when
the pandemic hit
thousands of couples and all the experts
who guide them to the altar
suffered a devastating blow now there is
at least some
clarity if you're a spring bride you'll
have to cull your guest list back to
15 or 30 and if you're a summer bride
after the 21st of june you might just
might
be able to pack out those pews well
joining me to discuss
all of this bride-to-be sophie brown
who's postponed her big day twice
emma meek the owner of luxury bridal
boutique miss bush
damian bailey wedding photographer and
founder of the wedding industry awards
and sarah hayward a wedding planner
and a spokesperson for the uk weddings
task force hello to you
all uh sophie to you first as a bride
your dreams of your big day and they've
been
shattered twice now already just talk us
through what you've been through
yeah they have it's been um it's been a
long
wedding planning process actually much
longer than we
had anticipated um we were originally
supposed to get married on the 30th of
may
2020 um and by the kind of mid to end of
march last year it was just obvious that
that wasn't going to
to happen um we have a large wedding
it's up to 180 people
um and we wanted to keep it that way so
in may in sorry
march 2020 we took the decision to
postpone our wedding
until may 2021 um which at the time
we thought was perhaps a little bit of
an overreaction and i thought maybe we'd
get away with kind of pushing it back
by six or seven months and and now
here we are a year on and i've just
postponed our wedding for a second time
and so we're now
due to be getting married in september
2021.
it's really difficult isn't it that
uncertainty that you've been living
through will it won't it happen
in may everything crossed it is third
time
lucky for you uh with that date tell us
about
the original wedding date how did it
feel to you on that day knowing it
should have been
your wedding what were you doing that
day
yeah so um obviously it was 30 degrees
and brilliant blue skies and just kind
of
like the ultimate british summer day you
don't want it too hot on your wedding
day sophie
if there's any consolation you've been
far too hot
yeah very true um and actually we had
kind of
moderate expectations for just a nice
day at home you know
and we'd put a bottle of bubbles in the
in the fridge and we're just hoping to
kind of make the best of what was quite
a sad day and actually we were
completely overwhelmed
and friends and family throughout the
whole day were dropping off
we had some breakfast hampers lunch
hampers my friends coordinated
um drop-offs throughout the day so that
they delivered a wedding cake
flowers a veil confetti they tried to
make a first dance in the garden they
kind of
spread all of the wedding traditions out
amongst them throughout the day so
actually it was one of the most fun days
of the summer last year um even though
we were at home in our back garden and
not getting married as we had originally
planned
oh i'm really glad you you did have a
good day on what could have been a
pretty
depressing one for you well done to your
friends
at sophie sarah haywood um let's bring
you in because that
there's a personal element to this as
we're hearing from sophie and from so
many couples who were due to get married
and this is a whole industry that is
suffering
as well we do now have a little bit more
clarity
on dates is that enough
no it's not enough and we can see the
finish line now which is the only
improvement but an entire 14.7
billion pound sector has had to be on
standby
until monday in case they reopened
weddings which has cost billions of
pounds
we have put in a very credible support
ask
and we have been making the case for
months now
in direct talks with government with
minister scully in bays
with downing street explaining how we
are a safe
pair of hands weddings can reopen to
larger numbers than 30
as lockdown is eased and here's
i don't know what the polite word to use
is but from the 17th of may
1 000 people or a 50
capacity can gather indoors unless it's
a wedding
when it can only be 30. in a venue
that's strictly controlled
we have to do risk assessments anyway to
hold a wedding
we have to make sure the day goes
without clockwork anyway
whatever's going on in the room and
there is no
credible reason why this number is 30
we don't understand it and once again
we're being
forced to open when it isn't even
commercially viable
and worse than that opening at 15 or 30
means we're actually giving money back
from our already
depleted cash reserves and this industry
won't get to june
we won't be there to do many of these
weddings unless the government
gives us the support that we have asked
for and that we deserve
so really sarah you're saying that it's
a write-off until
june the 21st by which much of the peak
period for weddings is gone
and there'll be many businesses that
just can't survive until then
we're in quarter six of low season
or prohibited trading we now see that
the next quarter is gone
from easter weekend weddings
traditionally ramp up
our busy really busy season is april
through to october
we've got 250 000
postponed weddings to put into the
pipeline and because there's been no
clarity
as you've just heard from this lovely
bride to be
people are postponing not for the first
time the second time the third time
and more our staff are all still working
we're still maintaining venues and
infrastructure
still being making sure that everything
is ready to go out when it needs to go
out our staff are still working
we can't access furlough if they're
working we still have to pay
them and those that we are following
it's not free money we still have
have that have other costs on there as
well that we're required to make every
month
um in addition to that we're not
recognized as hospitality we have not
had access
to some of the things that they've had
such as the five percent
uh vat reduction and some rates relief
um and it's we're a sector on our knees
and there's
no reason for it we've got business on
the other side
we just need a support bridge because
even the most credible commercially
viable business
cannot go this long with zero revenue
and i hate to think that this is because
we are a sector dominated by women
and seem to be doing something frivolous
like plan parties
we're not we're serious business people
running serious businesses in a sector
that is worth
more than the ticket sales from live
arts
and more than the ticket sales from live
sporting and there is no reason
why we are not being supported through
to the other side
unless it's deliberate let's bring in
one of the the one man on our
weddings panel uh damian bailey then how
has this
impacted your business as a wedding
photographer
well sarah um i shot two weddings last
year
uh one in february before the lockdown
and a small one in december
when we were allowed to um it was
devastating not only for my couples many
of whom like sophie were postponing once
twice
three times but to not
be able to shoot weddings means no
income and that was extremely hard so
i had to adapt pivot all the watch words
that
all we've all been trying to to use um
do lots of family photography which was
great during the spring and the summer
when government guidelines allowed
and otherwise batten down the hatches
and wait because all my couples
who postponed from this year uh from
last year into this year
are just ready and waiting to get
married it's business delayed not
business lost and we just need to make
it that far
and that is the point isn't it surviving
until you can get going again
and once the government made the
announcement
on monday about this date and weddings
being able to go ahead we hope from june
the 21st i mean
what happened to your phone what's been
happening to bookings
well it's been fantastic um two types of
phone call
first of all brides and grooms couples
who have booked their wedding
in the spring this year uh postponing
sometimes
for the third time or fourth time but
also couples phoning with some level of
visibility now saying well look we're
going to go for it after the 21st of
june and keep our fingers crossed for
the numbers
that we want at our wedding so it's been
really encouraging
to see all those couples coming in um
they're waiting they're just waiting for
the green light uh
they can get married and we can all get
back to work yeah waiting
for the green light and of course one of
the big factors for anyone getting
married is the dress
uh emma meek uh you come back this from
the retail perspective what has it been
like
for you and for your brides
well i mean we've been an extended
support uh network from our brides from
you know last march the 23rd when the
sort of level of bomb drop that they had
put on their wedding plans i don't know
nobody could have ever seen anything
like it i think the horror
that they experienced to the money they
lost the emotional fallout from them
so we we've been really being a support
network for them trying to be
um as steady and as calm as we can from
a business point of view from retail
from a retail perspective
we had a deliverable product last year
even though weddings weren't going ahead
and i think we only had
10 or about 30 of our 300 weddings
actually happen
um our supply chains were solid and
we were expected to take deliveries as
shops
um and obviously clients were in a
contractual relationship though so they
needed to pay the balance of their
address which has been
really tricky to kind of we've had to
really think about our contracts we
think about our terms of trading
um but i but we weren't as we weren't as
affected as on the day suppliers last
year
we were able to do you know and the
business when we and the in the
um the times when we were open i'm
reliably informed by a peer in the
wedding industry that we only opened
um for 26 weeks at 48 weeks
in the last since lockdown so actually
trading was brisk when we did open which
really kind of underlines the fact that
how important
weddings are to people and actually
although
i think i've seen a number of companies
pivot and try and produce
micro wedding dresses and you know
suddenly jump onto a market really what
people want to do is hold on to their
big wedding
their plans and the dresses and and the
day that they they've dreamt of for
quite a long time
but actually what's where the retail
problem is now really is the fact that
we've got nothing in the pipeline now
and we are absolutely have been stone
cold shot cold in the what should have
been our busiest quarter
so we're down almost 100 on revenue on
quarter one of this year
so that will have a huge impact for
retail going forward and again we're
going to need some further financial
assistance or an extension of the
existing measures you know like sarah
was saying um
that you know this isn't something you
know to get to
the 12th of april before we can take any
new business is a very very long time
and we also have an obligation to the
clients who want to get married even
with micro weddings
in april and the big question is how do
we fit their dresses well i was just
going to ask you
emma about the practicalities about this
how a bride
sees a dress chooses a dress how you go
through the fitting process when you
have to maintain
social distancing when you shop shot
well i mean
last year obviously we fitted what we
could last year for the weddings that we
had but obviously if somebody pushes
their wedding back
a year say to may or to september they
don't want to be fitted a year ahead
so some of the things are necessarily
going to have to be fairly close to
the actual um fairly close to the
deadline of the actual wedding date so
we've had i just say i'm i'm kind of
surprised because i know the work that
task force
have been doing in actually feeding into
the government about the lead-in time
that's required
for all the different products and
services that go into a wedding and it's
very arbitrary still it's like you can
open on the 12th and it's like
what about the weddings that are going
to happen in march and april then the
micro weddings
what do we do about those because we
need to fit those and
i mean i would argue i think we could
all argue that we've seen fairly
lacks adoption of safe covert procedures
in supermarkets and things and i'm
standing here in a giant chapel
with acres of space cubic capacity loads
of air
and with full ppe i can fit dresses
incredibly safely
our protocols and our risk assessments
that we did
go we did to go back last july were
really safe so i feel that we're ready
to do this
and also i think the wedding industry
needs us to be able to fit dresses
to not give brides another reason that
they can't
fulfill their weddings up until june i
think that's i think we're critical to
that
sophie yeah so sophie brown let's get
your thoughts on that i mean
the build-up to wedding is really
exciting it's also quite stressful
as well yours has been going on for a
very long time
how prepared are you over prepared
potentially is everything
ready to go when you're yeah it
it pretty much was in march 2020
actually so had all of our suppliers in
place that you know you
spend um a decent amount of time finding
and working with and paying deposits for
and so we had we had everything in place
and all of our invites had gone out all
of our rsvps had come in
so i was actually at the point of kind
of table planning
and um you know where are people going
to be at what time
um when we had to postpone the plans
last year
and then um you know i don't wish to
sound too negative but actually really i
had a year
of not being able to get my hopes up at
all about this wedding taking place
because
i didn't know if we were going to find
ourselves having to get
you know cut a lot of people on our
guest list or whether we were going to
have to find new suppliers
whether we were going to lose all of our
money that we'd already paid so
um now having heard um the government's
announcement on monday
it's the first week in a very long time
that i felt um
excited about uh about having a wedding
again and excited about getting back
into those plans
yeah you were going to be 31 when you
got married it's gonna be 18 months
delay what impact does that have on on
your life and what you want to be
getting on with in life
yeah it's um it's yeah so i was supposed
to be 31 at the time of getting married
i'm going to be 33 if we are able to get
married in september which
it kind of it shocks me because um you
know in that time
we haven't been able to do anything and
i find that a lot of our finances are
tied up in the wedding so
we've kind of had to put moving house on
hold and when we'd like to move up and
ultimately you know we'd like to have a
year of kind of being married and
traveling and honeymooning before
thinking about a family
and but i'm gonna run out of time if you
know at some point we need to get on
with the rest of our lives
honeymoons is the other big question
isn't it sarah hayward whether or not
anyone will be able to go anywhere after
a wedding i think at the moment
what we all want is to get back to work
and for these couples to be able to get
married
would be great if they could have a
honeymoon after one step at a time
the cork has to come out of the bottle
and we're just
so shocked that after the very sensible
way the wedding sector organized itself
we put together a task force that the
government supported us
in doing we put forward safe and
credible proposals
and we put in our financial support
request well over a month ago
and there's no reason now for us not to
have been heard
and this is the thing that we're
struggling with and weddings have a
societal impact as well
we thought the conservative party stood
for family values
there's nothing celebrates family
more than a wedding nothing affirms the
very concept of family
more than a wedding and at what point is
this going to be recognized
because literally four
000 jobs are on the line uh and i've
just come out of a meeting i had to
leave it to come to this
with over 80 mps were championing our
cause
and we just had a meeting with a large
number of them they completely get it
and they're going to go out and lobby
for us and try and get that number
changed
when we get into step 3 from the 17th of
may
and try and get us some support and i
feel like the only person who isn't
listening
is sitting in downing street coming up
with some arbitrary number
in step three just because there's
alcohol around at a wedding
it is not credible that a thousand
people or a 50
capacity can gather indoors from the
17th of may
for an event except for a wedding it's
not acceptable
the chancellor delivering his budget
next week sarah what are you hoping to
hear from him in terms of
support for the sector we've put in
a very sound request
it was for 680 million pounds to get us
to the first of april
we've increased that by another 200
million the numbers stack up
more than 60 percent of our sector just
needed 10
000 pounds to get them to to easter
that's not a great deal of money in the
great scheme of things
the larger businesses the infrastructure
it needs
access to the things that that wider
hospitality have like i
mentioned the vat reduction and we need
an extension of existing
measures but next week we need to see
financial support
um and we need to we need to be
acknowledged we've contributed for years
building our sector to this massive
world-renowned sector
unaided that's probably why we haven't
been recognized because nobody
needed to hear from us before but we've
made our case
a world-class industry is at stake
we're the only country that has
galvanized its industry in the way that
we
have people are asking us to give advice
for overseas but our own government
despite saying they supported us has not
responded
to the requests that we made and it's
unacceptable
damien as well as your own business you
also talk to all of those within
the wedding industry for your wedding
industry
awards and and i wonder what your fears
are
for those suppliers within the industry
within the sector
going forward well i know that
many have already fallen by the wayside
unfortunately they just couldn't
survive as businesses in the wedding
industry because there were no weddings
there have been no weddings
but we're a pretty resilient bunch i
think and and what i've seen evidence of
is wedding suppliers
diversifying their their businesses
adapting pivoting
all these watch words and and just doing
the very best they can
waiting until they can get back to work
at weddings because
those couples like sophie and thousands
tens of thousands of others are ready to
get married
and are just waiting to do so so i do
think that once weddings are back up and
running
to a sensible normal level that um
those businesses will flourish again
because uh they're
talented professionals hard-working
creative resilient
uh through and through and we're
certainly looking forward to seeing them
all
in the awards and celebrating all the
successes that this in this industry
brings sarah you wanted to come in there
what we're asking for is a bridge to the
other side for all the reasons we've
talked about
that even the most robust business is
going to be struggling after
all these months of no commercially
viable business
it doesn't make any sense to let us fail
and we're not asking for much to get us
to the other side the entrepreneurial
spirit is well
a very safe and and well it's alive in
our sector
and it's not unreasonable when at the
other side we've got
all this work we've got 40 billion
pounds worth of work
in the post-pandemic pipeline within 18
months to two years
what other sector can guarantee that we
can guarantee it
if they'll get us to the other side and
26
of that 40 billion goes to the treasury
they're not even thinking like of this
with their business minds
we're represented by the small business
minister it doesn't make any sense
to let us fail yeah i mean i mean damien
engagements haven't stopped happening
because of pandemic people don't stop
falling in love
you're almost going to get to a point on
the other side of this where you've
built up so much demand and every all of
those dates are just
keep on coming how do you cope with that
well it's already happening um my
wedding bookings i shoot around 30 to 40
weddings a year normally
all those bar two went from last year to
this year but of course you've got
couples coming through getting engaged
all through last year who naturally want
to get married
this cut this year and it's just there's
very very tight availability and that
pushes on
into into 2022 as well so i've
definitely seen
um couples going for monday to friday
dates from monday to thursday different
days of the week
um but yeah it's a stressful time for
for these couples
uh sophie very very eloquently put you
know just now
it's really difficult for them and all
the businesses then having to juggle and
manage those postponements and
cancellations
it's stressful uh it's really difficult
um but um i i
you know as sarah absolutely riley said
we just
need some support to get to the other
side of this because our business is
waiting for us there
yeah and sophie you must have many
friends in a similar situation
as well and you're all juggling to try
and squeeze in and find dates around
each other
we are and so i've got i've got friends
and also family members who
um we'd kind of perfectly aligned our
weddings the first time around
and then tried the second time round and
and then happened to again the third
time and
you know one of our um best friends and
ushers is
not going to be able to make it to the
wedding um if he's able to go on his own
honeymoon
because you know they're also now
getting married this summer and
it's um it's all of those life events
being squished into such a short
period of time um because we haven't had
any other any other choice or any other
opportunity
and emma one final thought from you how
quickly
can you gear up respond the types of
lead times once
brides are confident they've got their
date in how soon can you act
we can i mean our industry is absolutely
desperate to trade you know we've lost
so much revenue productive revenue from
last year
and we've lost all of the revenue from
this year our designers i've been in
touch with big household names like
suzanne neville jesus pero
they're ready to deliver in any given
time that they've got
and we've got very very sustainable uh
traceable
deliveries so we can get deliveries out
there quickly we want to be able to
give people the dresses they want um
even for newbies just coming in for the
first time in april
my our emails were absolutely red hot
yesterday with people booking
as soon as they possibly could for april
for july and august wedding so the
appetite
for the industry as sarah said to get
back and start delivering the revenues
that the country actually needs is is
there we just need to be given
probably a more i think well as i say we
need to be able to also
be open for fitting sooner and i really
i hope that sarah can take that message
to paul scully as well
because it is so important that the kind
of ancillary and the feed-in to the
wedding industry
is something that can just happen it
can't just open overnight
okay uh emma meek damian bailey sarah
hayward
and sophie brown thank you to you all
good luck and particularly
uh to you sophie we hope you get that
day of your dreams come
september